c'est l'une des réponses du gouvernement
à la crise des gilet jaune engagé le
grand débat national
la mise en place d'une grande
concertation de terrain a commencé à
trappes derrière cette initiative la
députée nadia est ce que j'attends en
fait de ceux de cette journée c'est que
la parole soit vraiment ni la plus libre
possible que personne ne s'auto
censurent un débat sous forme de petites
tables rondes par thématiques avec à
chaque pôle un rapporteur général
pouvoir d'achat fiscalité les
discussions étaient bien nourris
si l'état mettez le doigt sur cette
fiscalité l'exil fiscal qui nous coûte
80 milliards par an il travaille entre
la france et rit beaucoup mieux les
représentants des associations de
trappes ont également soumis leurs idées
on voudrait que l'état reprenne la
gestion des bailleurs c'est à dire en
profondeur c'est à dire de ce qu'ils
font de l'argent dans les participants
ne venait pas à tous de trappes à
l'image de cet habitant militant pour
une meilleure fiscalité et avant de
faire une réforme fiscale commencé par
produire des richesses
moi j'écoute l'exemple que j'ai pris
vont distribuer les pommes elle va
produire les pommes certains citoyens en
ont profité pour interpeller la ministre
de la santé agnès buzyn souvent on a un
traitement par exemple pour quatre jours
où ça vous
une voix qui va durer le traitement 160
jours sur les traitements coup on est en
train de travailler sur la dispensation
médicaux enfin tout d'une part pilule
les élus locaux étaient également
présents pour ce grand débat il ya des
décisions de fond à prendre dans la
solidarité l'égalité
un certain nombre d'éléments
administratifs qui sont superflus on
peut moderniser la france
elle en est capable et elle en a besoin
deux heures des échanges qui ont permis
aux élus députés et à la ministre de se
rendre compte de la situation sur le
terrain entre tout ce qui est fait au
niveau d'un gouvernement et la façon
dont ça se concrétise dans le quotidien
des gens et bien il ya un énorme écart
c'est peut-être la leçon qu'on peut
tirer c'est que on doit se parler plus
fréquemment en direct tous les citoyens
attendent à présent la fin de ce grand
débat national pour voir sa finalité et
les décisions politiques qui seront
prises